[Music]
dating in the digital age can get a
little tough but we are here to help you
out from body language clues to how they
treat you when you're together you're
crying to be giving you hints that they
are into you if you are a first-time
viewer click the red subscribe button
and give this video a big thumbs up
because today we are revealing ten signs
someone likes you they get excited
around you when someone likes you they
aren't able to hold their excitement
back when you are around they may show
this by acting anxious or nervous when
in your presence
look for signs of nervousness like
sweating and blushing they may also just
be really happy to see you if they have
a huge smile and laugh at all your jokes
chances are they are crushing hard on
you their body language people can
express the way they feel about one
another without saying a single word
sometimes they don't even realize they
are showing signs of affection you can
tell someone likes you by paying close
attention to their body language if they
slightly mimic the way you're standing
or sitting it could mean they are
attracted to you if you notice their
feet are always pointed in your
direction or they tilt their head when
they are talking to you it's a good sign
they are interested they are playful
when someone likes you they may have a
flirty way of showing you if they get
physical with a little punch on the arm
or call you funny nicknames it's because
they like you
this is them being playful which is a
fun way of flirting when men are being
playful they may mock who they like or
challenge them to a fun debate or
competition when women are trying to be
playful they will tease or joke with a
person they are interested in they keep
communication open if you can't figure
out if someone likes you or not just
look at your phone do they call or text
all day every day if so that is a great
sign it doesn't matter what sex they are
if someone has a crush on someone they
will want to talk to them they want to
be fresh on that person's mind so that
someone else can't speak in and steal
their affection
so if the person you like always comes
up with excuses as to why they haven't
called or text you might want to
reconsider your crush they are attentive
people have a basic instinct to want to
take care of the people they care about
so if you notice someone paying close
attention to your needs
when you are around it might be because
they like you they can do this by
offering their coat when it's cold
outside or doing something as simple as
listening closely when you talk people
who are attentive to your physical and
emotional needs are trying to let you
know what a relationship with them would
be like their eye contact someone's eye
contact can review a lot about how they
feel about you but it gets tricky
because you have to pay attention to the
person's personality shy people usually
find it really hard to keep eye contact
to the person they like while outgoing
people usually show they're interested
by keeping strong eye contact then you
have to pay attention to pupils one few
lock eyes because when people see
something they like their eyes tend to
dilate people also tend to blink more
often when they're around someone they
like so pay attention they drop hints
some people have a hard time coming out
and letting you know they like you so
they may drop in if they ask you about
your significant other or talk about
your future plans we could be setting
themselves up to ask you out
they may also hint at you to make a move
women do this all the time they will
look at your lips or even tilt their
head so that you know they want to kiss
you these little hints may be hard to
pick up on but they are sure signs that
someone is crushing on you they find
ways to be alone if someone likes you
they will not only try to be around you
all the time but they will come up with
ways to be alone with you they may ask
you to be their study partner or tell
you to come over and ping whatever the
situation is it's because they want to
spend more one-on-one time with you when
someone gets you alone they are
attempting to get to know you better
and see how compatible you really are
they introduce you to their friends if
you have met your crushes friends it
could be a sign that they like you when
someone really likes another person they
don't hide them they will show them off
to the world and they would never make
them a secret plus they're going to want
to get the friends approval of their
potential new relationships so if you
have met their inner circle of friends
prepare yourself because you may be
changing your facebook relationship
status soon they ask you out at the end
of the day there is no better sign that
someone likes you and them asking you
Wow but there is been a trend Netflix
and chilling so you have to be careful
someone has to ask you out on an actual
day anything else means they may not be
taking you seriously when it comes to
guys liking someone they will do
whatever they can to try to impress them
which means going on actual dates and
not hanging out for girls if they like
someone they will go on a date if they
come up with an excuse to not go then if
it's your sign she just isn't into you
if you're crushed showing any signs that
they like you react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
[Music]